might not long now until prime
minister's questions strikes obviously
likely to feature let's chat to our
panel of MPS about that and what else
they think might be thrown at Rishi
sunak joining me for the conservatives
is Catherine Fletcher MP for South Rebel
there she is and in the studio for labor
we have Andrew Gwynn who's Shadow Health
Minister and for the SMP Angela Crawley
MP philanick and Hamilton East good
morning to you all thank you so much for
coming in Catherine thank you so much
for joining us strikes Catherine I'd
like to begin with you obviously it's
not going to be particularly easy
especially if you've got Mick Whelan he
was speaking to us obviously General
Secretary of aslift saying that his
Union is further away from a deal that
at any point because of quote the
behaviors of the other side's
negotiating team
well it's his job to say that he's a
union official but what we've got to do
is find a balance here between the right
for Mick and the organized labor to
strike but the rights of people that use
Services need to get to work need to get
to hospitality venues need to use
businesses need to get to school and so
I really think it's important that
everybody just keeps going and talking
with this and doesn't start to take like
intractable positions
okay Andrew what do you think do you
think that's the sense we're getting
that in these negotiations people are
still talking well I think these
negotiations not just with the uh rail
unions but with uh the uh the Health
Service uh sector uh and other parts of
the public sector uh are just ground
into the mud I think the government is
really bedding in for a long fight here
whereas I believe we should be properly
setting everything out on the table
discussing negotiating and trying to get
that compromise resolution to these
disputes so that particularly as far as
the Health Service is concerned which is
my brief that we get the NHS back on
that sustainable footing we get care
throughout the winter period without the
distraction of uh unnecessary uh strike
action that we are now seeing Angela
what do you think well I think what
we've saw is the government has been
absolutely in transition it's been
unwell willing to negotiate on Fair
terms and you can contrast that with
there in Scotland obviously there has
been strict activity the Scottish
government has got round the table it's
had conversations with public sector and
it's tried to reach resolutions and as
Andrew said I would expect the same from
the UK government and I haven't seen
that today okay well Catherine back to
you we had Robert Generac on earlier who
said that it would be the absolute worst
thing if the government met the demands
of trade unions do you really think that
there is a sense oops sorry my studio is
falling apart here do you think there
really is a sense
um
that
at these negotiating tables there is a
sense that they're they're moving
forward when all we hear from the
government is oh it's unaffordable we're
cutting inflation we're focusing on
cutting inflation
so this is not a direct negotiation in
most instances between government and
the union so the these independent pay
bodies for teachers for nurses were set
up to de-politicize this to try and
avoid situations like this the
independent pay bodies let's take the
teachers for example we've accepted the
recommendations in full in terms of what
they said was affordable what they said
was appropriate and that means every
teacher will get at least a five percent
and starting salary for teachers would
you know I think it's nearly nine
percent eight point nine percent
something like that the the idea that we
ask a bunch of relevant experts in the
field to make an assessment of what they
think of fair pay is the government then
accepts it and then we find ourselves in
this position again I find quite
difficult to be honest I think what we
want to be able to do is make sure that
people can get the services they need
teachers do a fantastic job nurses do a
wonderful job and I do worry that by
making it all about pay and making
enormous paid fans demands so there's a
there's a risk that the economy becomes
over inflated we've got to battle
inflation because that will make us all
poorer if we don't get on top of it and
I think it's the responsible thing to do
to make sure that we keep the big big
question of inflation in our Mind's Eye
and I think that's what the independent
pay bodies have done as well so I do
want to carry on talking and I know we
are but we cannot just write blank
checks for for people we've got to find
a balance to make sure that we come out
of this really difficult economic
context but it is a war on you know
we're all running suffering the effects
post covid we've got to get out the
other side we've got to get inflation
down you know you'll hear the Prime
Minister today at pmqs talk about his
pledge to halve inflation that's vital
for all of us
uh go ahead Andrew well of course uh
Catherine uh is right that the pay
review bodies have come to a conclusion
but they came to a conclusion before the
conservatives totally crashed the
economy with their Reckless approach in
the mini budget but having said that
this isn't just about pay the government
has known particularly in the department
for Health and Social care for quite
some time that there are a range of
issues uh that the workforce are
massively uh over pressured uh they are
undervalued and there are real Workforce
retention and recruitment issues in the
NHS and that is part of the discussion
that the government ministers have got
to have with the nursing unions about
how we put the NHS on that sustainable
footing for the future because these
issues are not going away which is why
we are proposing one of the biggest
Workforce expansions in the nhs's
history because that is the root cause
of many of the issues that we are seeing
in an NHS that's under pressure but if
you look at the figures the government
keep telling us they've got record
number of doctors and nurses in the NHS
14.1 billion pounds they're going to put
in in the next two years that's a huge
amount of money it is a lot of money but
with that investment also has to come
reform and look there are massive
vacancies in the NHS as well so we need
even more nurses we need even more
doctors to be able to resolve the crisis
and that is what we are doing with a
fully funded plan uh to get that extra
investment into the NHS but the quid pro
quo for having an increase in the
workforce is to have that reform so that
we drive down the waiting times we drive
down the waiting lists and we improve
patient care considerably compared with
where it is at the moment Angela um I
just want to get your thoughts and bring
you in and in general the argument
obviously with a double-digit pay Rises
is that you're going to embed inflation
you're going to embed inflation in the
economy and it would just spiral and be
completely out of control that's what
the government says and that's why they
always have this target of halving
inflation by the end of the year do you
think that's a valid argument this
government has a responsibility in the
versions to manage the economy and what
we've seen let's be clear in the last
years we've seen three prime ministers
we've seen a government who Kamikaze the
economy and it is their responsibility
to manage inflation and to manage public
sector P now what we have not seen is
any guarantee of workers rights any
guarantee of protections what we have
not seen is a fair negotiation and an
open and honest discussion about the
rise in the cost of living about the
cost of living crisis that many public
sector workings workers are if it's just
not affordable if we don't have the
money
how are they going to do it but you're
asking people under exceptional
circumstances to go to work every day
when they can barely afford to pay their
Rising energy bills the cost of living
the cost of food and it's simply
non-negotiable that we don't have that
conversation to make it affordable for
people to live their daily lives that's
the government's responsibility and the
government by not negotiating by being
intransigent on trade unionism and by
attacking workers rights to strike does
nothing to resolve these issues the
government is not responding to the
crisis and it's not responding to
people's concerns and that's the real
problem here Catherine what do you think
so there are still strikes in Scotland
the the you know the negotiation from
from this the health is a devolved
matter in Scotland there are still
strikes there so the idea that the
negotiation is a Panacea for some that
that it doesn't really work for me and I
think the thing that I noticed from both
Andrew and Angela is they are saying you
need to go and negotiate but they're not
committing to what level of pay they
would be negotiating to that is they're
in opposition it's their job to this
their job to kind of um push and
question the government but we're not
actually hearing concrete plans we're
recruiting more nurses we've got the
highest number of doctors in the NHS
ever I think we're putting huge amounts
of money in it we're trying to reform it
we're engaging getting on the waiting
list down and and we've accepted the
independent pay bodies um
recommendations you need to actually set
up what you do as an alternative and
show that demonstrate that it works and
I don't think Angela and Andrew are
quite doing that okay we're gonna have
to leave it next we've got just a couple
of minutes three minutes until pmq
starts Catherine Fletcher Andrew Gwen
Angela Crawley thank you so much for
coming in and talking to us this morning
right let's bring in our political
editor Beth Rigby who is here morning to
you bear so we've got three minutes to
go it's all going to be about strikes
isn't it I think it's going to be about
strikes and the Health Service not least
because we're going to have an
announcement uh just after prime
minister's questions about one o'clock
we think about whether or not there will
be further ambulance strikes now I spent
a bit of time with the GMB Union on
Monday where they were discussing
whether to announce more strikes this
week and the mood music certainly was
that there could be more ambulance
strikes on the way and I imagine that
kistama will want to hone in on the
nurses strikes the ambulance strikes and
the crisis in the NHS and people not
getting the service they need what do
you think is going on here Beth do you
think they're adopting that age-old
negotiating tactic of stalling
who the government yeah well look I
think inflation goes down even more look
I think the government have had a very
clear line which is that they do not
want to reopen pay deals to the year to
April 2023 they argued that that uh WIll
Stoke inflation but there has been a bit
of shift in with Rishi sunak at the
beginning of the year saying I want to
talk and behind the scenes there are
lots of Creative Solutions being
discussed around the table about do you
give nurses a one-off payment do you
back date the April 2023 to April 2024
pay rise to January to give effectively
a three-month uplift to some NHS workers
do you try and give a a really good pay
rise in April 2024 and then instead of
often public sector workers have to wait
for those pay Rises agreed in April they
don't kick in until August do you make
sure they get a concrete pay rise from
April these so all of the things that
are being discussed but at the moment
there's no solution and the difficulty
for the government is that these strikes
are running into not just January but
February and even Beyond and I guess
there is a hoping government that the
public lose patience with public sector
workers but all the polling suggest that
the public are definitely on the side of
nhos workers and the people they're
blaming are the government for not
actually resolving it from a public
perspective you pay taxes to get Public
Services delivered to you and the person
that takes your taxes and then is
expected to deliver those Services is
the government so at the moment the
fault is is being laid at the feet of
the government but you you will see
Rishi sunak I imagine come back uh to
labor attacking labor for not backing
you strike legislation and he will make
the argument he made last week which is
we're trying to put minimum service
levels in and you aren't back in the
public on this it's interesting I'll go
back to what Mick Whelan said this
morning he was talking to Kay he said
I've never been in a process where
people are being so underhand and
deceitful and I've been negotiating at
all levels in this industry for about 38
years do you think this really is the
worst place that we've ever been in when
it comes to Industrial action I think
certainly we haven't seen this level of
strike action since the 1980s so this is
a kind of once in decades moment but of
course we haven't seen inflation at the
levels that we have for many decades
either and it is really putting a strain
on public sector workers I think public
sector workers in the Unions would say
that the government trying to put
through legislation in order to contain
strike action at this time does not help
industrial relations and of course the
unions have made it very clear that if
the government does pass this
legislation that they will challenge it
in the course so you know the argument
would be that doesn't help this
situation but from the government's
perspective their counter argument would
be it's not unreasonable to ask a key
public sector workers to have minimum
service levels and you know this has
been going on since December and it's
still rumbling on and and the people
that are really suffering here are the
public
um good afternoon if you're just joining
us uh it's one minute past midday let's
go straight to the comments from across
the house will be a shocked and appalled
as I am about the case of David Carrick
the abuse of power is truly sickening
and our thoughts are with his victims
the police must address the failings in
this case restore public confidence and
ensure the safety of women and girls
there will be no place to hide for those
who use their position to intimidate
those women and girls or those who have
failed to act to reprimand and remove
those people unfit from Office Mr
Speaker this morning I had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
thank you Mr Speaker as the project
Champion for the north Midlands
manufacturing Corridor no next week I'm
bringing together businesses leaders and
local councilors from across the region
in Parliament to set out to department
for transport officials the importance
of the A50 A500 Corridor the Prime
Minister understands the importance of
investing in our infrastructure and
unlocking the potential of our towns and
cities so will he urge government
colleagues from Bays and dealock to
attend the meeting and to hear more
about the benefits this investment would
bring to our region
Mr Speaker the government recognizes the
Strategic importance of the A50 A500
Corridor to the Midlands I know final
decisions on this scheme will be made in
the Third Road investment strategy which
is fully published next year but I know
my honorable friend will be contacting
ministers in the relevant departments to
invite them to hear her case we now come
to the leader of the opposition
thank you Mr Speaker can I join with the
prime minister in his comments about the
Dreadful case of Carrick
Mr Speaker it's three minutes past 12.
if somebody phones if somebody phones
999 now because they have chest pains
and fear it might be a heart attack
when would the Prime Minister expect an
ambulance to arrive
[Music]
Mr Speaker it's absolutely right that
people can rely on the Emergency
Services when they need them and that's
why we're rapidly implementing measures
to improve the delivery of ambulance
times and indeed urgent and emergency
care but I'd say to The Honorable
gentleman if he cares about ensuring
that patients get access to life-saving
emergency care when they need it why
won't he support our minimum safety
legislation
Mr Speaker the Prime Minister could
deflect all he likes but for the person
for the person suffering from chest
pains the clock started ticking straight
away every minute counts that's why the
government says an ambulance should be
there in 18 minutes
in that case it would mean just about 20
past 12. now I don't I know he doesn't
want to answer the question I asked him
so I'm going to ask him again when will
that ambulance arrive
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker because of the
extra funding we're putting in to
relieve pressure in Urgent and Emergency
Care departments because of the
investment we're putting in an ambulance
call handling we will improve ambulance
times as we are recovering from the
pandemic and indeed the pressures of
this winter but I say to The Honorable
gender again because he meets my case
for me he describes the life-saving care
that people desperately need so why when
in other countries like France Spain
Italy and others why is he depriving
people here that care
Mr Speaker he obviously doesn't know or
doesn't care I'll tell him if our heart
attack victim had called for an
ambulance in Peterborough at 12 O3 it
wouldn't arrive until 10 past two
these are our constituents waiting for
ambulances I'm talking about if it was
Northampton it wouldn't arrive until
order Mr blister
I hope you want to see the rest of the
questions though because I want you to
be here but you're gonna have to be
better come on
speaker I'm talking about our
constituents if they were in Northampton
it wouldn't arrive until 20 past two if
they were in Plymouth it wouldn't arrive
until twenty to three
that's why someone who fears a heart
attack waiting more than two and a half
hours for an ambulance
not the worst case scenario just the
average weight so from one week will he
stop blaming others take some
responsibility and just admit under his
watch the NHS is in crisis isn't it
Mr Speaker I noticed that one place The
Honorable gentleman didn't mention was
Wales
well we know ambulance times are even
worse than they are in England Mr car no
and the reason the reason that is the
case because this is not about politics
this is about the fact that the NHS in
Scotland in Wales in England is dealing
with unprecedented challenges recovering
from covid dealing with a very virulent
and early flu season and everyone is
doing their best to bring those wait
times down but again I'll ask him if he
believes so much in improving ambulance
wait times why won't he support our
minimum safety legislation
Mr Speaker he won't answer any questions
and he won't take any responsibility
clock our heart attack victim is in a
bad way sweaty dizzy
chest tightening
this is a heart attack and they're
shouting this is your constituent by
that time they should be getting
treatment
but an hour off they've called 999
they're still lying there waiting
listening to the clock tick how does he
think they feel knowing an ambulance
could be still hours away
well Mr Speaker the specific and
practical things we are doing to improve
ambulance times are clear we are
investing more in Urgent and emergency
care to create more bed capacity we're
ensuring that the flow of patients
through Emergency Care is faster than it
ever has been we're discharging people
at a record rate out of hospitals to
ease the constraints that they are
facing and we are reducing the call out
rates by moving people out of ambulance
tax and being dealt with in a community
now these are all very practical steps
that will make a difference in the short
term but I ask him again and again and
we know why the reason that he is not
putting patience first when it comes to
ambulance waiting times is because he is
simply in the pockets of his Union
paymaster
Mr Speaker this isn't hypothetical this
is real life
Stephanie from Plymouth Stephanie from
Plymouth
was battling cancer
when she collapsed at home
her mum rang 999 desperate for help she
only lived a couple of miles from the
hospital but they couldn't prioritize
her
she was 26 when she died waiting for
that ambulance
a young woman whose life was ended far
too soon and said Dad I can't even
fathom that pain
so on behalf of Stephanie and her family
will he stop the excuses stop [ __ ]
the blame stop the political games and
simply tell us when will he sought out
these delays and get back to the 18
minute wait
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker of course
Stephanie's case is a tragedy of course
people are working as hard as they can
to ensure people get the care they need
but he talks about
[Applause]
Healthcare I've already mentioned what's
been going on in Wales is he confident
in the labor on Wales NHS that nobody is
suffering right now of course they are
Mr Speaker because the NHS everywhere is
under pressure what we should be doing
is supporting those doctors and nurses
to make the changes that we are doing to
bring the care to those people but I'll
ask him this if he is so so so concerned
so concerned about making sure that the
Stephanies of the future get the cares
they need why why is he denying those
families the guarantee of emergency
life-saving care
so that's his answer to Stephanie's
family
deflect blame others never take
responsibility
just like last week he won't say when
he's going to deliver the basic minimum
service levels people need Mr Speaker
over the 40 minutes or so that these
sessions tend to last 700 people will
call an ambulance two will be reporting
a heart attack
four will be reporting a stroke but
instead of the rapid help they need many
will wait and wait on weight so if he
won't answer any questions will he at
least apologize for the lethal chaos
under his watch
[Applause]
he asked about the minimum safety levels
we will deliver them as soon as we can
pass them why won't he vote for them
first of all but Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
we are we are delivering on the people's
priorities as we've seen this week The
Honorable gentleman will just say
anything if the politics suits him it's
as simple as that he will break promises
left right and Center he promised to
nationalize Public Services he promised
to have a second referendum he promised
to defend the mass migration of EU and
now we're apparently led to believe
I expect that from Branch just to keep a
little quiet because if they don't
there's somewhere else them to shout
their lives
Mr Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if we are going
to deliver for the British people people
need to have strong convictions but when
it comes to the honorable gentleman he
isn't just for the free movement of
people he's also got the free movement
of principles
[Applause]
on Monday the independent Net Zero
review was published by a man rubber
friend the member for Kingswood
does my right honorable friend join me
in welcoming many of those
recommendations and in particular to
provide Clarity and continuity to all
those working to decarbonize our economy
especially those supporting social
structure climate Action Group in my
constituency
well Mr Speaker can I thank my right
Uncle friend the member for Kingswood
for history but also pay tribute to my
right honorable friend for his work in
this area I'm pleased that the report
recognized the UK's leadership in
tackling climate change and catalyzing a
global transformation in how other
countries are dealing with it we have as
a report of knowledge exceeded
expectations to decarbonize and were
responding to the full range of the
reviews requests and recommendations in
the coming year
they did the SMP Stephen Flynn
Mr Speaker to promise is acing to keep
it as another
well the Scottish government kept their
Manifesto promise to the people and
thanks to support from members of all
political parties in holyrood the grr
bill was passed surely in that context
the Prime Minister must recognize that
it is a dangerous moment for Devolution
when both he and indeed the leader of
the opposition seek to overturn a
promise made between Scotland's
politicians and Scotland's people
yeah well Mr Speaker let me be crystal
clear that the decision in this case is
centered on the legislation's
consequences for reserved matters
as is laid out in the Scotland act which
established the Scottish Parliament
which The Honorable gentleman talks
about and at the time supported by the
SMP this bill would have a significant
adverse effect on uk-wide equalities
matters and so the Scottish secretary
with regret has rightly acted
Mr Speaker let me be crystal clear this
is the conservative party seeking to
stroke a culture war against some of the
most marginalized people in society and
Scotland's democracy is simply
collateral damage and on that issue of
democracy let's reflect because on
Monday the UK government introduced
legislation to ban the right to strike
against the express wishes of the
Scottish government on Tuesday they
introduced legislation to overturn the
grr against the express wishes of the
Scottish government and this evening
they will seek to put in place
legislation that rips up thousands of EU
protections against the express wishes
of the Scottish government are we not
now on a slippery slope from devolution
to direct rule
yes no no misters no Mr Speaker of
course we're not this is simply about
protecting uk-wide legislation about
ensuring the safety of women and
children this is not about the
Devolution settlement I would urge The
Honorable gentleman and his party to
consider engaging with the UK government
on this bill as we did before the
legislation passed so that we can find a
constructive way forward in the interest
of the people of Scotland and the United
Kingdom effort Jensen thank you very
much Mr Speaker the care education and
support that children receive in their
earliest years has the biggest impact on
their future life outcomes and that's
why the affordability accessibility and
quality of child care is so important
for families in eldersbury and right
across the country yet despite
significant investment by the UK
government since 2010 for too many
families the child care system remains
inflexible complex and expensive so can
I ask my right humble friend to restate
to this house his commitment to address
this essential and pressing issue so
that every child can have the best start
in life
well I know this is a topic my honorable
friend knows very well from his own
background and he's right that it is
essential to access quality child care
which is why we provide every three and
four year old eligible with at least 15
hours a week of free child care and
we're considering new plans to improve
the cost choice and affordability of
child care whether Consulting on ratios
or indeed supporting more people to
become child minders
foreign
secretary employing NHS workers are
deliberately putting people in danger I
Health secretary putting dedicated
nurses against vulnerable patients does
the Prime Minister really expect the
public to believe that the very people
who have dedicated their lives to saving
life and land are so reckless or is it
not the case that this government have
pushed them to their absolute limit and
they have no other option but to strike
Mr Speaker we have enormous respect and
gratitude for all our public sector
workers especially those in the NHS
which is why we have backed them with
not just record funding but also record
investment in more doctors and nurses 15
000 more doctors thirty thousand more
nurses and more life-saving equipment
which will help them do their jobs and
we continue to want to engage
constructively and dialogue with them
David Simmons
well thank you Mr Speaker ruislip
Northern and Pinner has a great many car
dependent older and disabled
constituents many of whom are horrified
to read that the mayor of London may
have manipulated the outcome of his own
consultation
may have manipulated the outcome of his
own consultation in order to impose an
unwanted 12 pounds 50 daily charge every
time they go to a medical appointment or
attend hospital so does my right or
friend agree with me that any further
rollout of the Euless should be paused
until these matters have been fully
investigated
well my uh my honorable friend has
rightly pointed out that transport in
London is devolved to the labor mayor of
London and is disappointing that the
mayor backed by the leader of the
opposition is choosing not to listening
not to listen to the public expanding
The Zone against the overwhelming views
of residents and businesses I urge the
mayor to properly reconsider and respond
to these serious concerns
Mr Speaker the Prime Minister showed his
card this week by ramming through the
sacking nurses Bill he because
he has he has literally gone from
clapping nurses to sucking them his
transport secretary has said that the
bill is unworkable and the education
secretary has said that it is not it is
not needed why does he still want the
bill
Mr Speaker it was the labor party that
showed their cards this week when it
came to backing working people what I'd
say what I'd say what I say to The
Honorable gentleman but I'd say what I'd
say to The Honorable gentleman if he
really cares about supporting patients
if he really cares about children
getting the education they receive if he
really cares about working people be
able to go about their lives free from
disruption he should join actually in
legislation which is prevalent in many
other countries ensure minimum safety
levels in our critical public services
and get off the picket lines himself
thank you Mr Speaker continuing a theme
evidence is now very clear that the
London mayor's sham consultation has
suppressed 5 000 negative responses from
members and supporters of fair fuel UK
of which I am the appg chairman now what
angers me is this is a tax against my
residence in South thanage it's a tax
against Kent residents it's a tax
against all of the home counties this is
true taxation without representation and
I uh when will I write honorable friend
assure me he will do all that he can to
stop this because it is a tax that is a
fill up against a failed mayor's budget
and a failed mayor
well my my honorable friend makes an
excellent and Powerful point the labor
mayor is imposing this tax on a public
which does not want it he's right to
highlight that expanding this loan is
not something that communities want and
I look forward to working with him to
urge them man to properly consider and
respond to all these views and stop this
unfair tax when David
Mr Speaker during a period of 12 months
two of mycophilic acid ones have lost
their lives after being attacked by
dangerous dogs a 10 year old boy and a
senior citizen
fatalities have also occurred in other
parts of the country
it is clear but the dangerous dogs act
is woefully inadequate yes but
government has commissioned studies it
is debated the subject at length but it
has done nothing my question is when
will a government take action on the
issue of dangerous dogs
well my uh minor The Honorable gentleman
raises a very important case and I'm
very sorry to hear about the specific
families that he mentions and we
recognize that dog attacks can have
horrific consequences and I want to
assure him that we take the issue
incredibly seriously and that's why
we've established a working group
between police local authorities and
other key stakeholders to consider all
aspects of tackling irresponsible dog
ownership that working group will make
its recommendations later this year and
of course the government will respond
promptly Karen Bradley
speaker Mr Speaker Steph schmullen's
District Council run by the
conservatives has an excellent track
record of delivering from my
constituents whilst keeping council tax
low we have put a bid into the leveling
up fund and I know that that money would
make such an incredible difference to my
constituents so what he used his good
office to encourage the department for
leveling up to look favorably on us this
week
well
my my vulnerable friend has been a
store-bought Champion for her community
and in particular they're leveling up
fun bid which I know will make a massive
difference to her community I wish her
and her constituents every success when
we announced the next successful round
of bidders to that fund it's all agreed
thank you Mr Speaker many of my
constituents in chesham and amishim are
struggling to keep up with their energy
bills this winter when they do fall
behind two often families are punished
by being switched over to prepayment
meters which are more expensive which
does nothing to help the financial
situation will the Prime Minister back
our call to buy energy companies from
forcibly installing prepayment meters
and stop energy companies from switching
smart meters over to prepayment meters
remotely
well Mrs Mr Speaker I want to assure The
Honorable lady that off gem actually has
specific regulations in place regarding
the use of prepayment meters and how
energy companies should treat those that
are struggling with their bills but what
I am pleased to say is that her
constituents will receive around 900
pounds at a minimum of support with
their energy bills this winter as a
result of the actions of this government
well my reliable friend join me in
paying tribute and thanks to the several
thousand people at mod defense equipment
and supporter Abbey Wood in my
constituency who worked tirelessly to
ensure that the military equipment and
supplies that we have pledged to the
people of Ukraine are dispatched quickly
and efficiently and does he agree with
me that events in Ukraine are a reminder
yet again of the need to invest more in
our own Sovereign defense manufacturing
capability
well Mr Speaker makes an excellent point
and I'm happy to join him in paying
tribute to his is constituents at the
mod facility the work they are doing is
making a critical difference in the
fight to combat Russian aggression in
Ukraine I know it's extremely
appreciated both by the president of
Ukraine and his people and he's right
also that it highlights the need for
more investment which is why we're
putting 24 billion pounds of investment
in to our Armed Forces but also
increasing the amount of kit that we
manufacture here at home elaborate thank
you Mr Speaker
secretary at a visit with the British
rule site in my constituency promised
the company a hundred million pounds and
proudly boosted to the National media
that he couldn't think of a better
project that better demonstrated
leveling up yesterday the company and
our Administration haven't received not
a penny and financial support from the
government what the Prime Minister agree
with me that there's not a single
project in the country that better
demonstrates the government's lack of
industrial strategy failure of leveling
up an abandonment of the Northeast
well Mr Speaker first of all let me say
my thoughts are with the company's
employees and Families
time and we stand ready to support those
impacted now let me just let me just
outline photographer what exactly has
happened we did offer significant
support to British Vault through the
automotive transformation fund
considerable amount of funding but
entirely reasonably and it's not
something I expect the labor party to
understand that support was conditional
on the receiving private investment as
well which I think is a sensible
protection for taxpayers unfortunately
that didn't materialize but I think it's
completely wrong it's completely wrong
to take from that about the what else is
happening in the Northeast across the
Northeast there is new investment in the
new Envision and Nissan plant in
electric vehicle manufacturing a billion
pound investment in the Northeast just
look at what's happening in t-side or on
clean energy this government is
committed to the Northeast and it will
deliver more jobs and opportunity under
this conservative Administration
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
Prime Minister has long been a friend to
business as Chancellor he listened to
businesses in Stoke-on-Trent Central
about their issues Stoke-on-Trent has a
wide range of manufacturing fabrication
and Engineering Excellence does he agree
with me that growing these activities is
a vital strand of our leveling up
Ambitions and may I invite him to
revisit my constituency to meet with
them yeah why uh my honorable friend is
an excellent Champion for her
constituents and particularly her
Advanced manufacturing businesses which
I've had the pleasure of visiting with
her in the past it's important that we
support those businesses on Energy
prices which we are doing through the
announcement the chancellor recently
made particularly with regard to
generous support for energy intensive
Industries and indeed they can also
apply for up to 315 million pounds of
capital grant funding to help them make
the transition to Net Zero oh Butler
thank you
Mr Speaker when I had breast cancer I
had phenomenal nurses when I had to be
rushed to the a e the ambulance crew
looked after me Unison GMB they're on
strike because no one's negotiating with
them Mr Speaker for the first time the
Royal College of Nursing history they
have balloted and they are on strike
today I spoken to the generous Secretary
of the RCN she's adamant she wants to
end the disputes she just needs a
meeting with the Prime Minister will the
Prime Minister show leadership and meet
with the rtn just a simple yes or no
Mr Speaker at the turn of the year the
government wrote to all unions including
the LCA to invite them for for Frank
open honest two-way dialogue with
relevant Secretary of State I'm pleased
that those meetings are happening in a
range of sectors and I hope that we can
find a constructive way through this
because we approach Holocaust Memorial
Day colleagues can sign the early day
motion they can sign the book of
commitment they can attend the various
commemorative Services I have to report
some very sad news to the house that the
well-known Holocaust Survivor Ziggy
shipper died at the age of 93 in the
early hours of this morning he
went he was a survivor of auschwitzburg
canal and stutt house sort of
concentration camps he spent his life in
this country spreading his message of
Hope to young people
well my runnable friend join with me in
thanking Ziggy for his life for his
message which is very vitally important
as we sit here today
do not hate
well Mr Speaker I'm very sorry to learn
that Ziggy has passed away and my
thoughts are of course with his family I
know he was a man with wonderful
wonderful energy and humanity and I pay
tribute to him for his work and indeed
all Holocaust Survivors who have so
bravely shared their testimonies we must
have never forget the Holocaust and as
my honorable friend rightly said I know
the whole house will join me and him in
echoing Ziggy's message which is
poignant and accurate do not hate REM
Stringer
we'll leave prime minister joining his
conservative predecessors in
guaranteeing that the hs2 project
reaches Manchester or does he still
believe that investment should be taken
for poorer areas in the north and given
to the more affluent parts of Kent
Mr Speaker this government is investing
record sums in transport infrastructure
across the country but especially in the
north and Midlands with a 96 billion
pound integrated rail plan which will
improve Journey times east west across
the North and connectivity across East
Midlands it's a record we're proud of
and now we'll get on with delivering it
Mika there's been a 40 increase in
patients on roll with GPS in biggleswade
in the last 15 years but last week
proposals for biggleswade health Hub
were not progressed despite support
financial support from conservative
controlled Central bedfordshire Council
so can my right honorable friend advise
me what is the status of our Manifesto
commitment to infrastructure first and
will he and his ministers work with me
to bring together the various parts of
the NHS to bring the biggest whale
biggleswade Health Hub back on track
well I'd be very happy to organize the
meeting for The Honorable gentleman to
discuss how to progress his project he's
right about the importance of primary
care there is more investment going in
well we want to make sure it works for
his constituency and I look forward to
arranging a meeting with him with a
relevant Minister a girl school thank
you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister as
well aware of the
interview because he commented on an
earlier in a question because it's
long-standing hire tariffs and higher
Social charges why then has he allowed a
situation where hundreds of thousands
have been forced into that penury at a
time when winter is upon us and prices
are rocketing and where we Face a
situation of 8.4 million people facing
fuel poverty in April all he requires to
do is to instruct through themselves or
through a minister of jam to ensure that
there's an equalization of tariffs
between debit and credit and also that
his government takes steps to provide a
fund for those who have seen debt arise
because of his government's failures
will he aim that manifest and Justice of
the poor paying most yeah yeah well Mr
Speaker I think the honorable Jensen's
proposal would also increase bills for
many millions of families so I'm not
sure it is the right approach but what
we are doing is providing around 900
pounds of specific support with all
families energy bills this winter
there's further targeted support for
those who are most vulnerable was
absolutely the right thing to do and as
a chancellor has already announced we're
Consulting on what the best thing to do
going forward including options as you
mentioned such as the social tariff as
part of our wider reforms to the Retail
Energy Market Laura Faris
thank you Mr Speaker every single
country in the G7 requires some level of
minimum service to be provided when
strikes take place in essential Public
Services often with laws that actually
go much further than that does my right
honorable friend agree that the British
people should be entitled to the same
basic level of protection when strikes
take place in these services and does he
think the former labor Prime Minister
Tony Blair had a point when he said last
year the big defect at the birth of the
labor party was its tie to organized
labor
well Mr Speaker
this is my normal friend put it very
well but she's right to make the point
that what we're proposing is in line
with the vast majority of other
countries around the world indeed many
countries ban strikes and blue light
Services altogether we are not doing
that we are joining countries across
Continental Europe and having minimum
safety laws which I think reasonably the
public would expect to have a level of
emergency life says it life-saving care
in the event of strikes I think that's a
common sense reasonable position to take
and we all know why the party opposite
can't bring themselves to support it
thank you Mr Speaker this month the
writing member for stratford-upon-avon
was forced to pay millions to hmrc to
settle the tax dispute was the Prime
Minister aware of the investigation when
he appointed him to his cabinet and as
chairman of the conservative party will
the Prime Minister demand accountability
from his cabinet members about their tax
Affairs
well Mr Speaker my uh honorable friend
has already addressed this matter in
full and that's nothing more that I can
add
speaker if I may I would like to begin
by putting on record this house is
heartbreak at the tragic death this
morning of our friend Dennis the
minister of interior Affairs in Ukraine
and his deputy and all those who were
killed in that tragic accident I'm sure
there's parts of the house is United and
are feeling on that turning to more
local Affairs as many have pointed out
but government I understand is in the
final furlongs of giving out its
leveling up bids and I must ask him to
look kindly upon building the borough
Market of the Midlands and building a
future meditech Hub in Rutland so can he
assure me that not just Urban but also
rural areas will be leveled up
Mr Speaker let me join with my honorable
friend in in paying tribute to the
family of the Interior minister in
Ukraine I know our thoughts will be with
him at this difficult time and also I
can confirm to her that this government
believes leveling up should apply
equally everywhere across our United
Kingdom urban and rural communities up
and down the country will get the
benefit of having the investment that
they deserve making sure that we can
spread opportunity and ensure everyone
has pride in the place that they call
home
[Applause]
[Music]
devolved parliament in the world yeah
the Prime Minister continues to block
this Scottish parliament's clear mandate
all these Scots to choose their own
future and on Monday he sent his MP3
Lobby to deny Scottish workers right to
strike despite overwhelming Scottish
Parliament opposition and Tuesday they
sent his secretary of state for Scotland
to block an act of the Scottish
Parliament voted for by 70 70 of msbs
including Tories did you still think
that David Cummins ridiculous
Association holds any water whatsoever
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker there have been
347 acts passed by the Scottish
Parliament which is undeniably one of
the most powerful devolved legislatures
anywhere in the world in this
exceptional case it's clear that the ACT
does have adverse consequences for
uk-wide equalities legislation so in
those very exceptional circumstances the
Scottish secretary has regretfully taken
the decision to block passage of the
legislation but as I said previously we
want to engage in a dialogue with the
Scottish government to ensure that we
can find a constructive way through
Arabs to be able to control our borders
so I was very pleased that the Prime
Minister made one of his five priorities
the need to stop the boats in the
channel
can you reassure me and my constituency
Newcastle underlying not only will we
bolster the patrols on the French
beaches but we will make sure the people
who do make that dangerous journey and
arrive are removed
oh Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
right that this is a priority for all
our constituents he's right to highlight
the New Deal that we have with France
which is which increases funded patrols
on French beaches by 40 and as he said
we must go further to solve this problem
once and for all and that means
introducing new legislation that makes
it unequivocally clear that if you enter
the UK illegally you should not be able
to stay here but instead will be swiftly
detained and removed Imran Jose fine uh
Mr Speaker last night the BBC revealed
the foreign office knew the extent of
Narendra modi's involvement in the
Gujarat Massacre that paved the way for
the persecution of Muslims and other
minorities we see in India today with
senior diplomats reporting that the
massacre could not have taken place
without a climber of impunity created by
Modi and that he was in the fco's own
words directly responsible for this
violence given that hundreds were
brutally killed and that families across
India and the world including here in
the UK are still without Justice does
the Prime Minister agree with his
diplomats in the foreign office that
Modi was directly responsible and just
what more does the foreign office know
of his involvement in this grave Act of
ethnic cleansing
well Mr Speaker the UK government's
position on this has been clear and
long-standing and hasn't changed of
course we don't tolerate persecution
where it appears anywhere but I'm not
sure I agree at all with the
characterization that The Honorable
gentleman has put forward that completes
prime minister's questions I'll just let
the chamber player
as I said he did refer to the David
Carrick case but um the heated debate
shall we say was about ambulance waiting
times again sickest armor bringing up
specifically two hours what was it two
hours 40 years 40 minutes yeah but just
before we get into pmqs because there is
some other breaking news which is that
the former environment secretary George
Eustis uh wants you know in cabinet for
a number of years has just announced
that he is going to stand down as an MP
at the next general election uh he said
it was a difficult decision but after 15
years as an MP he wants to take the
opportunity to have another career
outside politics he served under uh
Boris Johnson as the Secretary of State
for the environment um and he's the
latest conservative to announce he's
standing down you remember last year's
Sajid Javid uh said he would he did an
interview with me on my show about why
he was leaving politics and it all leans
into this idea amongst senior Tories
that maybe it's time to ship out that
they might not win the next general
election so that's the latest senior
conservative to stay he's standing down
but yeah to get back to prime minister's
questions as we expected uh Kia stammer
going in on ambulance delays
specifically there's another reason he's
doing that today because at one o'clock
we expect to find out whether there will
be more Nationwide strikes from
ambulance workers in February and
potentially into March and I was with
the GMB Union early in the week as they
were discussing this with members these
were closed meetings but certainly the
mood music coming out of those meetings
was there was no resolution on pay and
there could be further strikes so this
is likely to hit the bulletins today and
here starmer in the chamber really
pressing the Prime Minister on ambulance
delays and what he did was he started
off with a hypothetical question about
if you had chest pains how long might
you want to wait for an ambulance and he
then turned that hypothetical question
into a real life story about a young
woman called Stephanie who was a cancer
sufferer lived in Plymouth the hospital
was just 2.3 miles away from her home
her mother called an ambulance it didn't
arrive Stephanie lost her life and she
was just 26 years old so he used her
example in the comments I have to say
the chamber went silent at that moment
and then after or during prime
minister's questions labor then put out
a press release as you were talking
about saying 37
000 patients with conditions like heart
attacks and strokes have waited more
than three and a half hours for an
ambulance in December so labor really
pressing in on this as for the Prime
Minister he did as we suspected he would
he said I am trying to make sure there
are minimum service levels when they
that strikes new labor are not backing
me and you're not doing that because he
would argue the Prime Minister you're in
the pocket of the Union so he brought
back in uh to point uh this idea about
minimum service levels and kirst armor
retorted by saying you there aren't
minimum service levels on normal days
for the NHS so another uncomfortable
prime minister's questions there uh for
Rishi Suna because these battles go on
over strikes and as I said before prime
minister's questions from a government
point of view
um they are content in the the
contingency plans that the cabinet
office put in place uh for for military
staff to man ambulances to try and keep
service levels they are they are pleased
in a way with their contingency plans
that they did work
um and their hope is I guess
um that they can keep those contingency
plans go in but the problem they have is
the public do not blame Poland suggests
public sector workers for the strikes
they blame the government for not
resolving them and there is sympathy for
public sector workers that work really
hard and they'll suffering because of
these crazy levels of inflation that is
really eaten into people's wages and
cost of living so another round of
strikes do still negotiations ongoing
but I would argue that the pressure on
the government to try and resolve this
is ratcheting up as the strikes look to
go not to January but into February and
March and it's going to be another set
of bad headlines for the government
today when as I suspect at one o'clock
ambulance workers announce more strides
okay we'll leave it there Beth but we
would of course bring you if there is an
announcement from the GMB Union we'll
bring that to you live Beth thank you so
much